another victim of this frightening
illness another victim from an ethnic
minority black and Asian people are
succumbing to this invisible killer and
it's happening at an alarming rate
Nadine Noah was just 48 years old a bus
driver in London a father of five it's
incredibly heartbreaking to have like my
dad taken away so at such a young age
because like he won't ever see his
grandchildren he won't ever see you know
any of us getting married or you bone he
won't be able to you won't be able to
have any of those memories his father is
now amongst the more than 13,000 dead
since this outbreak began but it still
is early days in this pandemic and the
signs suggest black and Asian people are
being affected by Kovach 19
disproportionately but the question is
why simply this virus doesn't
discriminate lifestyle choices social
and cultural ways of living vary and
different ethnicities and for the high
number of deaths in these ethnic
communities their way of life could be a
huge contributing factor despite only
accounting for 13% of the population
many be AME people are key workers on
the front line 44% of NHS doctors and
24% of nurses are from black and ethnic
minorities multi-generational living is
also a factor Bangladeshi households
account for almost a third of England's
23 million overcrowded houses Pakistani
and Indian homes are also more likely to
have more people in them there are
existing health inequalities - people of
South Asian descent are six times more
likely to have type 2 diabetes than
white Europeans certain communities of
ethnic groups are more affected by the
virus whether there's greater
circulating spread where the more needs
to be done to isolate certain groups of
individuals that can only occur if we
have more testing more data and more
analysis that what is going on not just
in hospitals but also within the
community setting and today responding
to Sky News the government confirmed
they will carry out a review
we've asked public health England to
look at this in some detail
and then what we really want is if we
see any signal at all we want to then
know what next we can do about it to
minimize risk but to be at this point in
time whilst the age comorbidity and
gender is clear this is not yet clear in
terms of ethnic minorities and we need
to look at this more carefully and get
this right for now a review won't
prevent people from dying there still
needs to be questions and answers about
why people from this community are being
hit the worst in German rasheed Sky News